Hééé bien bonjour
Je suis aujourd'hui avec Maxenss , Carlito et Lepérave
Les amis aujourd'hui on va jouer à un jeu auquel on jouait quand on était tout petit , qui s'appelle .....
CACHE-CACHE !!!
On va faire ça en trois manches.
À chacune de ces trois manches les deux équipes iront se cacher à tour de rôle bien évidemment
Puis ce que vous avez tout le temps que vous voulez pour aller vous cacher
Quand vous êtes cachés vous nous appelez et vous nous dites
"J'suis caché !"
A partir de là, à l'aide de nos Honor 9 Lite, qui sponsorisent cette vidéo,
Merci, merci d'avoir proposé cette opportunité
Thanks Honor for the opportunity
On pourra savoir où vous êtes sur Google Maps car on a partagé nos positions
On sait où vous êtes, nous deux on vous rejoins en véhicule motorisé
Une fois qu'on arrive sur place on a 15 minutes pour vous trouver
Si on vous trouve on gagne un point car on vous a trouvé dans le temps imparti
On va alors se cacher et c'est ensuite à vous de nous chercher
Je vous laisse deviner qui d'entre les binômes sera le meilleur
Je suis avec Maxenss, Raphaël est avec Léo
Je suis avec l'étoile montante du YouTube
Si vous gagniez vous voulez qu'on fasse quoi?
Je veux qu'il imprime une photo de moi sur un t-shirt et qu'il la porte sur la prochaine vidéo
Oh c'est bien !
Moi j'aimerais que Lucas porte un petit chapeau de fête dans sa prochaine vidéo
Juste au début ?
Non non toute la vidéo
Ah !
T'es prêt ?
Le ralliement ouais !
Allez ! Ah ouais
Honneur aux invités, ça commence
Maintenant
Allez, en avant! Go
Attends, avant la tempête le calme
Ligne 14... mais non mais non. Oups
OUUUUUUPS
Mais ils sont cons
Tu veux que je te dises un truc vieux
Si ça se trouve ils vont se cacher dans le bâtiment ici
C'est le seul bâtiment qui est pas privé du coup vu que c'est notre bureau
Comme vous pouvez le voir derrière nous nous avons des sosies
De moi même et de Carlito
Sauf qu'en fait on va les placer quelque part dans la rue
Justement très prêt de là ou il y a le bureau de Luca
Et nous par contre on sera vraiment caché dans un
Container électrique
Et on va semer le doute à l'aide de ces faux sosies
Ah ils bougent ça y'est
Je tiens à vous dire que Luca m'a appelé en disant
"Putain mais vous êtes pas partis le point bouge pas sur la map"
Ca c'est très bon ça !
En fait on s'attendait à ce qu'ils bougent
Ils sont là depuis si longtemps mec
Un binôme ici s'il-vous-plaît
Ah ils nous ont bait les bâtards
Ils se sont mis juste à côté et ils vont trouver un truc chanmé juste à côté
Donc on va les appeler pour leur dire qu'on est cachés
Personne ne regarde ça les gars, personne !
Vous regardez là-bas, vous faites votre vie
Ca peut pas être un bâtiment. Qu'est ce qu'il y a dehors ?
C'est soit un arbre.. dans les égouts.. sous terre genre ?
Ca sonne ça sonne
Ils nous appellent, ils nous appellent
Allo vous nous entendez ?
Oui on vous entends !
On est d'accord que le point n'a pas bougé là ?
Non
Ok y'a clairement un bug
En tout cas c'est pas grave, on s'en bas les couilles. Ouais bon bref..
Nous sommes cachés !
Attends mais comment on vous retrouve ?
Oh ils nous ont bait, ils ont dit "On est d'accord que le point a pas bougé?"
"Bon bah y'a un bug"
Ok c'est des mythos ils sont juste à côté
Maman je t'aime !
Oh putain y'a pleins de gens de couleur
Oh non les bâtards !
Ils ont mis des leurres !
Max le compteur est lancé on a que 15 minutes gros !
J'ai grillé lui là bas.
Le mec à bonnet orange
Ok on va voir on va voir
Y'a leur cadreurs qui sont là
Y'a leurs cadreurs qui les suivent plus frère
Vas-y go, allez Max. Maintenant va falloir courir un peu par ce qu'on a plus trop de temps
Merci les faux Mc Fly et Carlito c'est cool
Ils sont dans webedia
T'es sûr ?
Ouais franchement je pense, allez viens.
Je suis presque sûr qu'ils sont ici
Ca capte trop mal, et on a pas le droit d'aller dans des bâtiments auxquels on a pas accès
Pourquoi y'a plus leurs cadreurs ? Pourquoi ils sont plus filmés ?
Ah je sais Max !
Quoi ?
Y'a plus leurs cadreurs par ce qu'ils ont des GoPro
Et ils doivent être dans un endroit où ils sont cachés vénère
Et ils peuvent filmer qu'à la GoPro
Je deviens parano
Je deviens parano de ouf
Mec si ça se trouve ils sont juste dehors
Ils nous voient de là où ils sont c'est sûr
Bah oui !
C'est sûr ils nous voient de là où ils sont
Si ça se trouve ils sont dans un truc comme ça t'sais
Ah non y'a une clé c'est pas possible
Ahhh on tente ?
Tu veux l'ouvrir ?
Test mais je pense ..
Ça s'ouvre pas, ça s'ouvre pas
Oui allo
Alors les garçons on ne trouve pas?
Les gars vous avez pris le seul bâtiment autorisé vous êtes trop malins
Le temps est écoulé nous avons gagné !
Bien joué bravo à vous
Bien joué, ils étaient à l'intérieur
On vous propose de sortir du bâtiment
Attends avant ça dites "Vous êtes vraiment les meilleurs, vraiment meilleurs que nous"
Vous êtes vraiment des bâtards vraiment plus malins
On verra sur les prochaines les gars
Attendez bougez pas on arrive
Je te l'ai dit !
Putain !
Je te l'ai dit!
Mec c'est des faux trucs
Mais oui, c'est des faux. Y'a jamais eu ça.
Tu viens tous les jours ? Quasiment ? Tu t'es dit..
Je me suis dit c'est une nouvelle install.
Les gars, les gars bravo pour ce point
On vous a pas trouvé vous avez gagné un point
Vous allez vous changer par ce que c'est pas du tout votre style habituel
Et on va nous aller se cacher pendant ce temps là
Et peut-être que notre idée est mieux
Max, c'est à nous de nous planquer vieux
C'est parti vieux
Nous venons d'arriver sur le lieu de notre première cachette
qui n'est pas des moindres
puisqu'on va se planquer sous l'eau, sous une barque
avec un tuba, on sera invisibles
Le seul moyen qu'ils nous voient, c'est qu'ils soient
de l'autre côté de la rive et qu'ils voient le tuba dépasser
parce que d'ici, il sera planqué derrière les barques donc ils le verront pas
Ok, clairement ils sont près de l'eau
On y va comme si c'était un peu la chasse au trésor
Allez c'est parti !
On y va, go !
C'est celui-là,c'est celui-là !
*rires de Carlito*
Ils font ça tous les jours
Ils en mettent du temps, hein, il se passe un truc clairement
La c'est pas un changement de fringues seul
par ce qu'ils prennent beaucoup trop de temps pour mettre un t-shirt
*cri de Squeezie*
Ou alors ils se déguisent, avec un maquillage, ...
Y'a un problème avec la combi de Max
elle accroche beaucoup trop
*cri de Maxenss de galère*
Ca lui arrache tous les poils
Route de la Muette à Neuilly
S'il vous plaît
On arrive, petits canards
Oulah, ça appelle
NOUS SOMMES CACHES
A tout de suite, les loustics
GO, GO, GO Max !
J'ai vraiment hâte de les voir déguiser en arbre
Allez go
On a 15 minutes, Léo
15 minutes !
15 minutes
Regarde le lac !
Trouve moi..LAC !
Là-bas, là-bas! Juste là
Mec, est-ce que si ils sont juste sur une barque,c'est nul
Bah nan, mais ils ont pas mis tout ce temps pour se mettre dans une barque !
CE JEU EST GENIAL !
C'est fou, regarde nous! On cours
Et les cadreurs sont obligés de me suivre là où je vais
même si ça n'a pas de sens !
*rot de Squeezie*
Ils sont là c'est bon !
Vous êtes Maxenss et Squeezie ?
On s'éloigne de là où ils étaient mec
On n'a plus beaucoup de temps là !!
Allez l'équipe là !
Bon apparemment c'est par là
Cherche dans les arbres
Peut-être dans l'avion là-bas?
Bonjour monsieur
JE SUIS IMBATTABLE A CA NORMALEMENT
Ah mais ils sont peut-être dans l'eau putain
Mec j'ai envie d'aller là-bas moi
Réfléchis au fait qu'ils aient mis une PLOMBE pour se préparer
Ok j'vais vers les bateaux, y'a des bâteaux
Vous avez vu des gens là dedans ou pas ?
Et nous, on peut y aller?
Mec s'ils sont cachés en dessous là-bas
On peut rien faire
Ouais mais c'est trop compliqué pour y aller
Mais c'est pas compliqué pour y aller
Bah j'y vais, j'y vais
Je suis désolé de te dire cette phrase mais vas-y vite
Allez Léo !
Oh la vache ! C'est casse gueule.
C'est bien là !
Putain si vous êtes pas là les gars je vous déteste
S'ils sont pas là c'est dingue
Tout ça pour rien
Putain mais ils sont pas là
Ils sont là ou ils sont pas là ?
Ce saut !
*Rire de Carlito*
Allez viens vite, j'ai d'autres idées
On vous a niqué
C'est bon j'ai eu un flash mec
C'est évident qu'ils sont dans l'eau si y'a un lac
C'est terminé !
Hey les gars !
Mais nooooooon
Mais qu'est ce que tu as fait ?
Mais je lui ai tout dit je suis désolé !
Il étaient dans l'eau
Mais je t'ai dit dans l'eau
Oh non on avait raison on a juste été nuls
On a manqué de réalisme dans la surface
Regarde comme il galère, regarde le, regarde le
Ce qui est génial c'est que à chaque fois on est vraiment à ça..
On était en stress, on a rapproché les barques le plus possible
Je suis espagnol, corse et algérien
Du coup j'ai beaucoup de seum en moi
Et là vraiment j'ai le seum
Attends mais Raph on perd pas là, ça fait un partout
Un partout les gars, il reste deux manches
Regarde il se fait une petite trampette
Mec le rêve
Là c'est à nous de nous cacher ?
On y va tout de suite
Allez foncez les gars, on se change pendant que vous allez vous cacher
A plus Maxenss
Nous sommes à l'église de Pompidou, j'ai pas le nom exactement
On va se mettre sur le balcon là haut
Déguisé en ...
Gargouilles !
Exactement
Faut pas que les gens nous grillent sinon c'est mort
Donc on peut pas s'installer et mettre nos costumes devant les gens qui sont en bas
Et on espère d'ailleurs que Squeezie va les croiser
et que ça va un peu le déstabiliser
Oui allo
Nous sommes cachés !
Ohhhh, ok les gars on est pas loin, on arrive.
Bon courage les garçons
Au revoir
Ils sont à côté de l'église Saint-Merry
La chance c'est que la y'a pleins de touristes
donc regarde les touristes
Si ça se trouve y'a des touristes qui vont regarder dans la direction où ils sont
Tu veux aller à la fontaine ? Mais oui viens !
Ok on va là où il y avait écrit [?]
Ils étaient là sur le plan à peu près
Là
Est-ce qu'il y a pas une entrée d'un tunnel où quoi ?
Ouais ouais, vas-y check !
Si y'a un toit de verre c'est qu'il y a un tunnel en dessous
"Danger de mort" Ouais c'est pas un vrai panneau
C'est pas du tout un vrai panneau
Si, ça c'est un vrai panneau
T'es sûr ?
Putain....
Ahhhhhhhh
Max max, te laisse pas déconcentrer !
Non mais je regarde, je regarde
Si ça se trouve ils sont parmis les gens qui nous prennent en photo
Non mais non
Regarde bien les gens
C'est vrai qu'il y a beaucoup de gens
Check bien les gens
Non si ça se trouve je dis ça mais c'est pas ça
Si c'est pas ça on passe pour des cons
Oui c'est pas ça, on passe vraiment pour des cons
Ca serait trop grillé s'ils se cachaient parmi les gens
Mais pourquoi y'a un groupe au milieu aussi ?
Y'a des gens qu'on connaît dans le groupe
Mais oui putain
C'est ça qu'est bizarre
Mais mec c'est vraiment un truc avec eux
Y'a des gens qui font coucou en plus
Ouais ouais ouais
Mais c'est ça le bait si ça se trouve
Bon on va plus là-bas ?
Oh là là
Mais c'est bizarre par ce qu'il nous regardait
J'avais l'impression qu'il nous regardait
Y'a rien quoi
Y'a juste une place avec des gens et on est paumé quoi
Attention ils rebiquent, ils reviennent
Si ça se trouve ils ont mis un gros make-up et on les reconnaît pas
Genre... Raph il a des cheveux
Y'a rien, y'a une place on voit tout
Y'a même pas de planque
Je sais même pas comment ils ont fait
Une minute putain, une minute les gars
J'ai aucune idée mec, j'arrive pas
J'ai aucune idée
Bon c'est bon là ?
En vrai y'a tellement rien
C'est terminé !
Ouhouuuuuuuu
Oh les bâtards
Impossible !
Oh les bâtards !
C'était fou ce moment les gars
Incroyable ce qu'il s'est passé
Les mecs !
Ohlala ils ont abusé
Et les costumes sont fous
Ils sont forts
Ils devaient tellement se marrer à nous voir, ohlala
Putain ahaha
Check de gargouille
Les mecs, on est arrivé sur une place y'a rien
Y'a une fontaine, y'a un million de jeunes qui nous prennent en photo
Je me dit, c'est sûr tout à l'heure ils nous bait en mettant des clones d'eux
Là ils font pareil ils sont déguisé en enfant
Et du coup je regardait très très mal tous les enfants
Je les regardais comme ça et tout
C'est très chaud par ce que au début les gens nous prenaient en photo
et ils nous faisaient des coucous
Ils pensaient que c'était un spectacle en fait
Ils nous voyaient arriver en gargouille
Il se disaient putain y'a un truc qui se prépare, trop cool
On était là avec nos grands doigts de gargouille
On faisait, cassez-vous cassez -vous
Du coup vu que c'est là mais ça faisait des coucous
Bah oui !
Ca vous fait un point de plus
Aller, on va se cacher ciao
Bon on se dirige actuellement vers notre deuxième cachette
Ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que entre les prises
on adore mettre l'équipe adverse sur de fausses pistes
Et là on leur a dit que cette cachette allait être extrêmement dur
alors qu'en fait c'est la plus simple des trois
Elle est évidente
On va faire ce que j'ai toujours rêvé de faire dans un cache-cache
Se fondre dans la masse
C'est parti !
Ca va être grillé mec
On va être grillé à mort
On réalise que notre cachette est nule
En fait il aurait fallu tous les cagouler les mannequins
Max on va se faire griller en une minute
Le plan de base a échoué
On voulait remplacer les mannequins
mais ça marche pas c'est trop grillé.. horrible..
Donc on va juste se cacher dans ces petits rayons
Et ce qui est bien c'est qu'on a mis 30 minutes à trouver ça
Ils vont penser qu'on a setup un truc hyper compliqué
Alors que pas du tout, on est vraiment entre deux fringues
Ohlala ça vibre, ça vibre !
Allo !
Attends attends, allo
J'suis caché !
On est caché
Ok on arrive
On va vous debusquer
A toute
Il étaient chauds, ils étaient en mode "On y va!"
Ok vite vite vite
Ils sont dans le coin, ils sont ici
Repère par rapport aux magasins autour
Tu choisis Châtelet pour un truc précis, tu vois ce que je veux dire ?
Putain ! Des mannequins !
Où des mannequins ?
Allons voir
C'est sur, très bonne idée
Bonjour
Bonjour comment allez-vous ? On peut rentrer dans le magasin ?
Absolument ! On arrive peut-être
C'est pas eux là ?
C'est toi ?
Je crois pas mec. Ca aurait été une très bonne idée
Putain mais c'est pas ça
On rentre quand même dans le magasin par soucis de sécurité ? Non ?
Non mais elles ont dit que c'était pas dans le magasin
Un ascenseur hors service
Et ils rigolent, la prod rigole hein
Alors vraiment c'est qu'on est vraiment très nuls
Ca rend ouf, ça rend ouf !
Je deviens fou
J'aime pas perdre en plus, vraiment
Ils sont clairement déguisé ou quoi
Ils sont où ? Non me dit pas c'est les mannequins
Mais genre ! Non mais non mais non
C'était ma première idée
C'est terminé !
C'est une blague ?!
*Squeezie rigole*
J'était sûr, elles disaient rien.
On était en train de roder dans le magasin, elles disaient rien les meufs
Je les regarde elles ont l'air tellement gentilles
Je suis là, oh mais je veux pas les emmerder
Par contre on était beaucoup mieux tu trouve pas ? Dans notre analyse ?
Le dernier on se plante pas
Ce jeux est autant génial qu'il fout la haine
Les gars les gars deux partout
Allez vous cacher, filez. Aller filez.
Ca me saoule !
Troisième manche et dernière
Bon écoutez on a pas besoin de vous faire un dessin
C'est incroyable ce qu'il se passe
On est donc en nourissons
Voilà, nous sommes des jumeaux
Des jumeaux clairement
En fait c'est beaucoup d'investissement
donc s'ils nous trouvent en moins de deux minutes vraiment on aura le seum
On est en train de recevoir le petit appel
Oui allo
Nous sommes cachés
Quoi ?
On fait un cache-cache là
Ah vous jouez à cache-cache ?
Ok bah on arrive alors
On veut bien jouer avec vous
A toute
Ca sature à mort
Ils sont colés
Ils ont un truc
On détecte tout de suite des indices, on est comme ça nous
Oh est-ce que je suis crédible si je fais
*Carlito imite un bébé*
Non ?
Allez let's go on y va
Pour moi ils sont sous des feuilles
ou dans une ghillie ou un truc comme ça
Ils peuvent pas être ailleurs tu vois
Ok on voit le lac c'est bon
C'est pile entre là où on est et le lac
Go go go
Max, allez active toi. Ils sont là-bas c'est sûr frère
Pour moi ils sont vers là c'est obligé
Pour moi ils  sont là, ils sont dans l'angle là
Si ça se trouve la statue c'est Carlito déguisé vieux
Si ça se trouve ils sont dans la poussette
J'y ai pensé mais non
Je dis que de la merde, je dis les pires idées depuis tout à l'heure
Pardon, pardon, désolé
Aller je te suis gros
Ouais mais impossible d'accès là
Ouais mais justement
Y'a des traces !
Y'a des traces gros on va les trouver
Je reconnais les traces de semelle de Raph
Ouais mais y'a que une paire de traces
Y'a rien à droite la haut ?
C'est plus sur le chemin, on s'est gouré
Viens viens viens, allez vite. Trace
Y'a pas une grotte là dedans
C'est interdit ça
Mec attends j'ai un doute
J'ai vu des pieds dépasser d'une poussette
Des pieds très grands
Viens on va vers les gens on leur dit "Est-ce qu'on peut voir vos bébés ?"
Faut oser
C'est trop bizarre
Je sais pas, le fait qu'il y ait deux poussettes collées une à une
On va demander, on y va tout doux
Ok on y va ensemble
Attends mais évitez de cadrer si c'est pas eux
Vas-y toi
Ils sont là
Ils sont là ?
Ouais
On peut voir vos bébés ?
Comment ?
Laissez les tranquille s'il-vous-plaît
On peut pas juste les voir ?
Mais laissez les tranquille merci
S'il-vous-plaît j'y tiens
Es-ce que .. non ça serait pas de la comédie ?
J'ai pas envie, merci
En fait c'est pour un cache-cache désolé
Ils ont des jambes immenses, il est bizarre le mec
Vas-y on y va, allez vas-y go
Monsieur
S'il-vous-plaît arrêtez
On veut juste voir vos bébés
Non mais ça devient vraiment...
Avec vos caméras...
Ca devient un peu agressif
Ca devient vraiment très agressif s'il-vous-plaît
Bon les gras on vous a trouvé on peut faire une photo
Allez photo, c'est eux. J'ai vu des mains dépasser
C'est grillé
*Léo et Carlito pleurent*
Incroyable !
On y a cru putain
Bougez pas c'est la photo
J'ai vu les chaussures dépasser de ouf
Mais toi t'as été incroyable
Mais t'as été incroyable
YES !
Bien joué
Attends j'ai des fourmis dans les pieds de ouf
Ohlala lala
Bien joué putain
Merci merci
Ah j'y crois pas
Quelle magnifique aventure humaine
Mec la cachette est légendaire
Elle est folle
Les mecs les mecs
Cette cachette était probablement l'une des plus fortes et amusantes de toutes
On remercie les comédiens qui sont partis
Plus le temps passe plus le flair est là bien évidemment
Bien sûr
Pour l'instant vous gagnez
Si vous nous trouvez y'a ex aequo
Si vous nous trouvez pas on a gagné
Mes bébés, je peux vous appeler mes petits bébés ?
Ouais
Bonne chance, aller salut !
Dans chaque vidéo il souffre
*Léo et Carlito rigolent*
Les amis pour cette troisième et dernière cachette, on a mit le paquet
Pourquoi on a eu cette idée? -Je sais pas!
On va descendre avec une corde, on aura notre ustensile pour laver les vitres.
On va vraiment laver les vitres. Avec un binôme qui va nous accompagner.
-Je pense qu'on est à... 40 mètres! -Le seul bémol,
C'est qu'il y a personne dans la rue.
Du coup,
J'espère qu'ils vont pas avoir direct l'idée de regarder en l'air.
Le fait qu'on soit 4 c'est cool...
Parce que ça va un peu...
*cris d’excitation*
Hé mec j'ai peur du vide...
*Cris d'angoisse*
Mais vu qu'ils ont la haine depuis tout à l'heure, je pense qu'ils auront les yeux partout. -Là ils ont la haine!
Qu'on les ai grillés en bébés.
Ils ont une haine incroyable!
Alors on va s'équiper. C'EST PARTIIIIT!
*Musique de suspense*
-OK les gars, je vais sur un truc:
Si en bas ils nous appellent, et qu'ils font "HÉ HO!"
Nous on va faire ça, et vous vous les regardez vraiment.
(Au téléphone) -OK les mecs on est cachés vous pouvez venir.
ON EST CACHES!!!!
*Musique de suspense*
-BON! Maxenss à eu un courage hors norme.
Moi j'ai fait la décalade au Canada, on s'en souvient!
Mais... Je me chie quand même...dessus!
*rire nerveux*
Très fort!
-Ils ont fait fort c'est sûr. Ils sont allés pousser un truc.
Loins.
FORT.
OK?!
*Musique de suspense continue*
*Soupir de stress*
*Musique prend fin*
3!
2!
1!
GO!
-La poubelle!
*Son du chrono*
-Attend je met la lumière.
-Nan y'a que des bouteilles.
*Porte en métal*
-Nan mais nan impossible.
-P*tain on aurait pu y entrer naturellement dans celui là!
-Ouais! ET MOURIR.
-Terrasse d'un café! Ils auraient pu penser terrasse d'un café!
Bonjour...
-Y'a quelque chose ou pas?
-Pas possible, ils sont si forts que ça?!
OLALA
-Quoi?
-Nan je pensais que c'était un faux mur p*tain
-Nan mais nan je crois pas.
*Musique chrono continue*
-p*tain...
WHAT THE F*******CK!!!
Personne ne fait ça à cette heure-ci gros!!!!
-Ouais c'est eux!
-Mais non!
-Oh la vache!
-P*TAIN
*Hurlements et musique de joie*
-Oh les bâtards!
Oh c'est magnifique j'ai envie de rentrer!
-Oh la vache!
-Regarde ça!
Attend c'est pas eux?!
-Mais si c'est eux!
-Mais sinon ils réagiraient!
-MAIS NOOOON! On va chez des gars,
N’importe-qui se retourne!
Là ils se retournent pas, c'est eux! regarde
-OH ils sont en train de laver u p*tain de velux!
*Rire hilare*
-C'est qui à gauche là? Ça va?
-Il s'appelle comment?
-Je peux voir le visage de Pierre steuplé?!
Et je te donne 7000 euros!
Merde il m'a montré son visage, c'est pas lui.
Sa mère la p*te
-Nan mais ça veut dire qu'ils sont à un endroit plus simple tu vois?
-Les buissons! Ils l'ont fait en buisson!
-Mais nan!
-Mais si je suis sûr
*Musique chrono reprend*
-Des monstres p*tain c'est des monstres!
Ils lavent rien du tout mec!
C'est des particuliers! Personne lave les vitres des particuliers!
*Cris de colère* NOOON
*Rires hilares venant d'en haut*
-On a gagné gros!
-Oh la vache mais vous êtes des malades!
Qui a eu cette idée de faire ça?
-Bravo cette idée elle est géniale!
*Bisou*
Olalalalalala -Magnifique
C'est le meilleur tournaaaaaage
-Oh la vache!
Olala le tournage de malade!
-Forcément "on vous a grillé" mais nous on était obligés de continuer.
Parceque... -Ah oui c'était drôle!
(Tout le monde parle)
-Moi j'ai vu un mec qui est rentré dans sa chambre.
-Il t'a reconnu
-Autographe et tout
-C'est ça selfie j'était derrière sa fenêtre comme ça!
-Donc 3 partout! Egalité parfaite!
Les gars vous avez trouvé des cachettes incroyables!
C'était FOU!
Merci Honor d'avoir sponso la vidéo,
Et d'avoir permis de faire des cachettes aussi violentes,
Et d'aller aussi loin dans le cache-cache!
Les amis, on espère que ça vous a plu.
N'hésitez pas à aimer la vidéo,
Si vous voulez un deuxième épisode un jour!
Peut-être dans un autre pays?!
A bientôt dans un prochaine vidéo
AUREVOIR
*Musique de fin*